they survived but no one here has been
spared the anguish their stories are
excruciating to hear let alone live
through
I lost my mother and brother-in-law I
had to carry his body from the eighth
floor and my mother was trapped on the
first floor we took their buddies out
with our bare hands because rescue teams
could not reach us the first day it was
pouring rain God turned this place into
a hell that day
we follow two clinical psychologists
with the Turkish red crescent into this
camp for displaced people they listen
hold hands
offer pads on the back and play games
with children
sometimes just offering a blanket or a
cup of coffee is Comfort enough in that
moment
if they don't have their secure shelters
if they don't feel themselves secure so
it will like so socially it will affect
them in such inner social behavior I
mean in a social way you you we could
have so many multiple
psychological problems like depression
major depression PTSD in some
personality disorders even the
psychologists say in the upheaval of the
earthquakes aftermath children are
particularly vulnerable
our youngest daughter is going through a
difficult time she was with her
grandmother when she died she went crazy
being outside in the rain alone while we
tried to reach her we're trying to heal
ourselves God willing we will the
president of the Turkish red crescent
says its ability to provide Mental
Health Services to survivors is quote
humble considering the enormous need
required in the coming weeks months and
years and that's why sustained
International Aid is essential
people repeatedly say they're feeling
hopeless and helpless
but over time experts say their
Collective trauma can also lead to a
communal healing
Natasha gname Al Jazeera antakya turkia